foreign
everybody it seems kind of bright in
here why is that
um we've been moving like we had lights
and [__] it's okay though because of
various things should be all right it's
because they're red back on the nudes
dude oh right right okay yeah we've
removed the lights around but uh that's
all right though yeah it looks okay
but uh yeah so happy Sunday you guys I
know we're on a little bit later than we
normally would go on on Sunday but
that's because busy schedule man we had
a busy schedule and uh we didn't
actually watch the movie until like just
now right it's a good movie like it
ended up yet okay yeah so what ended up
happening I know Danny rolling you
wanted us to do House of Wax however we
were out we went out to koiwan yesterday
for you know for our Saturday thing it's
like to get some food and when we came
back what was sitting there on our
doorstep but this little movie right
here
crank yep Senator Senate xanadas sent us
this because remember when we did
um the uh the Christopher Walken movie
uh King of New York and on there was a
trailer for this movie and you said wow
that looks really good and then a couple
people in the comments uh including
Tammy I think like said oh yeah that's a
really good movie uh so xanadas sent it
to us very kindly so thank you very much
yeah you got
um uh look at Amazon Prime it took like
the next day it was here yeah so yeah
like I said it was on our it was on the
porch like when we came back from lunch
on Saturday if you all have Amazon you
want to send us a video that's how you
do it it'll be here like the next day
they got good prices yeah that would be
the easiest thing so this was
delightful yeah this movie good we were
just laughing our asses off the whole
entire time it's an action adventure
gangster movie about a Hitman who's been
injected with this Chinese cocktail of
poisons that uh inhibits your endocrine
system you know when it comes to uh
making adrenaline and you if you stop
moving you slow down and you die but as
long as you can stay excited and fill
with adrenaline you'll stay alive
and he's he's trying to get revenge for
the people on the people so all kinds of
wild [__] just Shenanigans so it's not
you can't ever slow down if it slows
down he dies
it's kind of a comic book type movie uh
kind of like John Wick kind of thing uh
but the way it shots pretty artistic uh
it does comic book type stuff you know
split screens and does funny [__] like
[__] a dude speaking of subtitles
come up but then it goes back and it
looks at Jason Statham and the subtitles
are backwards like for the point of view
a guy talking all kinds of my favorite
thing was like do I have [__] written on
my forehead and then it's like written
on his forehead and I'm like yes it is
written on your forehead matter yeah
yeah this is very much I saw like a
review of this that actually pointed out
they said this is essentially like a
live-action version of Grand Theft Auto
yeah exactly which um well yeah and I'm
pretty sure that was intentional because
now that I'm thinking about it the
opening credits were like an 8-bit video
game yeah look to them yeah and it's
point of view it's POV like you're a
video game right it's good it's cool
yeah it's totally totally over the top
and ridiculous and it's like not
realistic in any sense of the amount of
you know of the word but it knows that
it's like that and it's just trying to
be like entertaining and also I yeah it
really leans into the Ridiculousness and
the outrageousness of it and it was a
lot more gruesome than I expected which
I enjoyed you guys know how much I like
that and it was much funnier than I was
expecting like there's a lot of black
humor yeah a lot of good humor in it
it's essentially kind of like and I also
I've also seen it compared to this like
I said it's kind of like the
over-the-top video game version of uh
DOA because wasn't that that same
premise where it's like somebody got
poisoned and they only had like I think
so however many hours like to find the
person that did it and that's pretty
much I mean there's there's like a whole
plot going on with all these gangster
you know the gangs and they're like
double dealing and all this other kind
of [__] and it's like you know you can
follow that if you want to but it's like
not important really though
really what's important is watching
Jason Statham just doing crazy [__] yeah
now I read on Wikipedia that he had done
all of his own stunts okay including
that [__] like near the end where he's
up in the helicopter okay hanging off
the side of the helicopter I think they
did that for real because I'm watching
it I'm like that does not look like
green screen yeah to me and I guess it
was not
uh they were 3000 feet up in the air I'm
like boys that takes some balls right
there I've always liked Jason Statham
and everything I haven't seen all of his
movies I'm sure there's some real bad
ones out there but I thought he was
great in The Expendables uh seen him in
a couple other like gangster flicks
and he's like one of the real good he's
like a British tough guy and he pulls it
off pulls it off he does it he's uh his
physicality kind of changes in every
movie and this one he's not quite uh
[__] his cut or jacked but later on
there's some other stuffer he's real
[__] cut up looking so he's on the
sauce but um he looks good in it
um he uh pulls off [__]
like you said a lot of stats yeah if he
did those stunts he did he does some
cool [__] good he's good you know what
in a way Jason Statham probably could be
a James Bond
I think he could I would yeah I would
watch that yeah he'd have to tone it
back and do the [__] Bond thing you
know maybe he could do it
I think I'm gonna check his his age I
think he's about my age I think he's
like 52. probably yeah I'm not really
sure uh xanderman really shits the bond
story should start he should be like
late 30s early 40s but right you know
xanada says I believe this was Jason
Statham's first starring role because
this movie actually came out in 2006.
okay
um and also says he was in one of my
favorite guy Richie movies Lock Stock
and Two Smoking Barrels that was a great
[__] I've never heard it yeah it's good
you'd probably really like it
um but it was a supporting role I think
that was the first time I saw him so
yeah this was kind of like this was
probably his first starting role so he's
well the funny thing about it is that I
mean he's a terrible person right he
just like kills people he doesn't give a
[__] like you know he threatens innocent
people and does all kind of terrible
[__] but it's so cartoonish like the
whole thing and like I said it's
deliberately like very over the top and
cartoonish that it's like you just can't
help but yeah but like enjoy it because
just like the crazy [__] [__] like
he's riding around in [__] he steals
a police motorcycle when he's has is the
whole thing and he has like a hospital
gown on with his ass hanging out and
he's like standing up on the [__]
motorcycle and [__] like that it's
[__] crazy yeah I think my favorite
well my favorite scene I think I think
the one that we laugh the hardest was
when
um he's trying to like he was in
Chinatown and with his girlfriend and
they were getting shot at and everything
like that and they you know like I said
he has to keep his adrenaline up so he
has to keep doing like exciting [__] or
whatever and so he just like starts
[__] her like in public yeah and
everybody says she's dancing I don't
know and they do it in front of the
Chinese people they're all just looking
good yeah and then eventually like they
start cheering yeah yeah even a busload
of Chinese schoolgirls or what
super funny how did that like that made
me laugh the hardest I think that whole
[__] scene
um the old lady was clapping yeah
look at him go and then like later on
like the one of the little Chinese
school girls is like yeah she had a he
had her up against the newspaper machine
like she's very he was very and his size
was enormous
they weren't girls though they were
there were girls in their 20s because
they almost look like like they were
everything's kind of comic book they
look like little Chinese porn stars is
what they look like yeah pretty much
yeah the whole [__] movie is good man
there isn't a bad part in this movie
yeah it really kind of just keeps on
going and you know what it's just like
John Wick it's [__] constant John
Wick's course higher caliber but this is
and it kind of you know similar similar
like except funnier yeah I do kind of
feel I'm glad that I saw somebody make
that comparison because this is very
much like a live-action Grand Theft Auto
yeah yeah it's just like like I said
it's not totally realistic but it's just
gets crazier and crazier and crazier and
just you know people get run over or
people get their hands chopped off
people just ridiculous
and I'm not [__] fully convinced that
he died at the end of the movie well
that's what I was going to tell you is
that spoiler alert
um there's a sequel okay they came out
in 2009 with him yeah okay it's called
Crank high voltage okay he must have
been alive yeah I gotta see that one the
whole the whole premise of that one yeah
is that he survived the [__] is if
you've seen it like at the end of an
airport he fell out of an airplane or
like a helicopter like however far it
was he's making a phone call he's
calling his girlfriend on the way down
like very fast
yeah and his girlfriend's like a
stereotypical super cute California girl
you know I mean who's [__] done kind
of dumb yeah you know dumb and doesn't
know what the hell's going on and she
bought all his lies that he was a video
game maker but no he was an assassin
it's good it's good good yeah she's just
she's actually a good character oh she's
real cute uh Amy Smart is her name um
probably you know her from uh Starship
Troopers she was a Starship Troopers
she's been in a bunch of other stuff too
but I know you've seen that a bunch of
people yeah she looked she looked real
familiar I couldn't yeah she was from
Stars Starship Troopers she must have
been real young in Starship Troopers
because she still looks younger than
this one well this is this is 2006 2006.
so this was a long time ago
it's an old movie she would have been
early 30s then which is weird because I
don't remember hearing about this movie
and it did really well I think like it
only cost 12 million to make only 12
million but you know what I mean that's
pretty low budget
um and it made 42 million so it made so
it did like pretty well and this is
Jason's first starring role so that's
that's what Xander does
yeah because like I said he had been in
Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels but
he wasn't like the lead role in that
that was kind of like an ensemble I I
[__] thought he was great in the
[__] Expendables Theory series and
some people say well Expendables 3
wasn't that good no Expendables three
the director's cut that you get on on on
Blu-ray I never seen the theatrical cut
they said the theatrical cut sucked
because you couldn't have any cussing in
it because it had [__] Chuck Norris
Chuck Norris he wouldn't allowed Chuck
Norris made everybody not swear yeah
what is he gonna call me up and tell me
I can't [__] swear on my own damn
show probably but Expendables 3 the
director's cut on DVD is the best of
them all I thought
I thought it was really good
I had Antonio Banderas in it he played a
real good character that can I see this
did I see the second or third one I know
you showed me the first one I don't
think you should yeah I thought the
third one was the best one but I don't
think I saw that because there's a lot
of [__] that veterans relate to
he wants to get back into the action but
he can't you know what I mean because he
didn't have any friends he talks too
much he's got a lot of PTSD problems
everything but then he
it's just it's just good he kind of ends
up becoming part of the team and redeems
himself and he's kind of like the lover
boy of the [__]
The Ladies Man of the [__] team it's
good it's good yeah he's getting a gun
fight and the girl's helping him female
soldiers helping him and part of The
Expendables and he's flirting with her
while they're shooting and fighting
because I've always loved you you know
Antonio Banderas
yeah it's great it's playing into his
like yeah yeah yeah that whole because
that's what his that's what his
archetype about his [__] that was his
[__] so he's doing this whole thing you
know yeah uh Danny Rowling said rock and
rolla was a good English gangster film
yeah I agree that was also very good you
would probably like that as well there's
a whole there's a whole sub-genre of
English gangster movies that you'll
probably be really into yeah I keep
trying to get you to watch layer cake
um that had Daniel Craig in it you would
probably oh I like that you would
probably like that send it to me I saw
that in the theater okay if you send it
to me I'll review it uh but no I've
liked every British gangster movie I've
seen yeah they're super fun even even
that old one with [__] um oh
dude it scares me from the hand what the
[__] Michael Caine one where he played
that assassin back in the 70s I think it
was the late 70s early 80s I saw that as
a kid that scared me I liked it though
Michael Kane scares Tom yeah but there's
a lot been uh British gangster movies
are good
said guy Richie's films are pretty good
yeah I've liked most of guy Richie's
Legend was great
yeah yeah yeah thought about the craze
yeah well there was a movie called The
Craze too like that's about but that's
also good but I don't think it's as
actiony you know what I mean
um yeah Danny Rowling said Statham is
the English version of Bruce Willis yeah
I can see that and Tammy says Bruce
Willis's ass though probably yeah I
think he's more like the British version
of probably closer to Stallone
yeah about like closer to Stallone
probably
uh Tammy said he's 55 years old he's 55
so about he's a little bit older a
little bit older than me yeah
um John Gora says crank is good Crank 2
is much better though really I rarely
like sequels but what I was gonna say is
that you know I guess this is a spoiler
but um you know this is an old movie but
uh so you think that he dies at the end
kind of well they kind of hint that
maybe
yeah because they there's like the
heartbeat thing and his eyes are open
and his eyes are open yeah so in the
sequel I think the sequel we haven't
seen it yet but I was just like reading
like a quick synopsis of it I guess it
picks up like just a couple seconds
later yeah so
um and what happens is I think from what
I could determine that some gangsters
steal his heart because of course they
do yeah and then give him like a fake
one that he has to keep like
electrocuting like to keep it going so
it's like the same premise but all right
but even more ridiculous like a
Frankenstein kind of thing I was like I
respect that though like I said if
you're gonna have a silly premise like
that [__] go with it have fun with it
it's the tone of the movie it makes
total sense in the context of the tone
of the movie it's a comic book gangster
video game movie like Grand Theft Auto
so of course they're gonna steal his
heart and put a [__] cybernetic yes
why wouldn't you and you gotta you gotta
see the sequel
because well now I want to see it that's
something to justify how he lived
and you're turning him into Robo yeah
you're already and you're already in on
the joke because you're watching this
[__] right you know right and if you're
watching two then yeah you're already
then you're on board you're already on
board you might as well
but no they did great man they did great
with the uh
uh the gags [__] he runs into this
[__] um uh uh all-black motorcycle uh
[__]
um clubs uh clubhouse and does all kinds
of cool [__] [__] snorting cocaine
off the ground I thought they'd do was
gonna make him make him suck his dick it
just kind of seem like yeah okay now
you're gonna have to pay for that free
he's like it's not free
but he pulls out money to get the
cocaine I suspect if he hadn't had money
then he would have yeah he'd have to
[__] go to work for it yeah but it's
it's a good flick man
I'm gonna say
the budget and the okay well [__] man I
can't say I can't just say it's not as
good as [__] John Wick it's just
different yeah it's not really the same
I mean John Wick has a certain tone to
it right is a lot more serious like it
does have some humor to it in the sense
that it knows what kind of movie it is
but this was much more comedic like it
knew that it was I wouldn't I wouldn't
outright call it a comedy but no it
definitely did have a very large like
comedic element too we all know what a
comic book movie is right this is kind
of like a comic book movie but not
really it's more like a video game movie
yeah and that they're they're taking
comic book movie to the next level this
is like a video game yeah and they let
you know early on this is a video game
movie they're giving you POV shots like
you're going through a [__] point of
view shooting game and
and so you're already suspended your
disbelief this is not reality they're
showing you it's better than reality
it's hyper reality yeah that's a good
way of putting it yeah and it's got a
great soundtrack a [__] classic 70s
[__] a happy you never know what
you never know what they're gonna pull
out of their ass anyway I love the
public Chinatown [__] scene which had
like the kind of it wasn't like Luther
Vandross what was it I can't remember
what song it was but it's a very classic
like was it making it all Liz yeah yeah
I was like yeah they're doing [__]
70z easy listening music if you [__]
falling only you believe
that oh that might have been 80s I think
was that Journey oh [__] no but I can't
remember who it was yeah it was just
some that was I I laughed my ass off
when he's just like falling out of the
helicopter like as he's falling to his
desk yeah like always then he's like
talking just just like chill on the
phone like to his girlfriend like yeah
well not even to his girlfriend he's
talking to her answering but yeah I'm
just I mean I called it man I saw the
[__] trailer and I said I like that
Jason Statham and just what the way the
trailer was I was just that mother that
movie's [__] ridiculous it's gonna be
good yeah and it was well like I said if
you're gonna have a ridiculous premise
like that then just like know you have a
ridiculous and just like have fun with
it and they did I mean it's a fun fun
movie if you haven't seen it see it I
recommend it it's a fun movie you can be
drunk and see this and [__] and still
absorb it you'll understand it because
it's it's simple yeah unless you want to
read into it because there's a bunch of
[__] happening with the gangsters it's
it's not as simple as it seems but you
don't have to know it you don't that's
not important like I said the kind of
the whole fun of it is just what crazy
[__] is he gonna do next you know
because he just does all kind of crazy
[__] like I said he's like [__]
riding a motorcycle like standing up
with his ass hanging out in the hospital
gown like he's [__] the chicken yeah
Chinatown he's like you know just
getting into fights deliberately there's
10 minutes of it he's [__]
he got rid of his clothes to put on a
hospital gown as a disguise because he
needed an effigent or what was it
epinephrine epinephrine
yeah so he had like all these nasal
sprays so he gets caught up he gets
caught up in a situation where he's
wearing a hospital guy with his ass he's
got to go through gunfights [__]
motorcycle chases and [__] [__]
ramping this cop motorcycle that he that
he [__] stole it's like a KZ 1100
like a chips motorcycle fully dressed
and [__] and uh his ass hanging
doing [__] stunts and [__] [__] it's
good everybody's like aghast at this
half naked [__] and he had a
huge on her too that's right you got a
[__] bone because because of the [__]
that he shot up he started [__]
rocking up like craziness it's bulging
in his [__] pants and the dude
standing next to him he's like looking
and look at him he's like
and it was like it was funny is that
they were unabashedly showing you that
his hard arm was a about a foot long
like yeah Jason Statham that's just
[__] 12 inches
it's funny man it's good but like I said
it's got a [__] ton of humor in it but
the tone is it's not you're not talking
about like airplane or anything like
that or yeah it's not like that it's not
that ridiculous it's just it's just
right it's not
it's a mixture gruesome violent
yeah I liked all the door I was in that
upbeat adventure and humorous [__] you
know what I mean a ridiculous [__] but
you're like okay yeah all right all
right yeah yeah I mean because well at
first because I was just kind of like it
seems like an action movie but then
there's that one scene where he goes to
that one gangster well the gangster's
brother like the guy that poisoned him
he's like trying to find him you know
what I mean to get revenge Jefferson
Airplane that's what they said yeah yeah
yeah and so he go and he legit like just
cuts the dude's hand off like with a
Cleaver like a meat cleaver and I was
like oh we're going a horror movie
around okay I approve yeah uh I approve
so yeah so like a lot later on like it
gets a lot um gorrier so there is kind
of like a lot of there's kind of some
horror movie [__] like people getting
their head blown off and all that kind
of crap so it is so it is like really
really
bloody and [__] like that so I like that
yes it's just it strikes a good balance
between
a bunch of different genres because it
does still kinda
honor the spirit of action movies and
honor the spirit of gangster movies it
does all that so it's not
it's not dishonoring any of those you
know a [__] cinematic traditions of
these movies it's honoring them it's not
dishonoring them it's good it's real
good I think I like to I think a lot of
the humor of it comes from all of these
ridiculous situations and like Jason
Statham kind of being I mean he has to
like rage out a lot of times but
sometimes he's just like super calm like
the I love the scene like near the
beginning where he first finds out about
this [__] and he's so he takes the car
and he's just like speeding and he's
like driving through a mall yeah and
he's like talking to his doctor he's
played by Dwight Yoakam by the way yeah
yeah I thought he looked familiar and
then I looked it up I'm like oh yeah
that's right it's Dwight Yoakam he's
like that country star but uh he was
great and I love the doctor yeah he's
like the gangster doctor yeah he'll
treat you at your house right he won't
tell the authorities right guys like
that actually exist although they're
well yeah there's a lot of times yeah
but so he's just like driving through
the mall just like talking the doctor is
like was in Vegas like getting you know
getting Happy Endings from the hookers
whatever they call somebody they're
getting blown or some kind of hooker
[__] that's going on it's good it's good
and likes you know so he's just like
well I've been ejected with this boy
that he's like describing it yeah and uh
you know the guy's like well I'm kind of
busy right now but I'll be back in an
hour like whatever because he's like at
the airport like waiting for his play to
go home and he's like what are you doing
right now he's like I'm driving through
the mall and then like he flips the
[__] car like onto the escalator
now you can see that I laughed my
[__] you can see that part of that
stunt was CG but it didn't matter
because the the way it was edited and
the [__] timing of the editing and
the tone of the movie fakeness kind of
worked in this movie a lot you know what
I mean yeah you could see that that was
CG uh but I also liked it although one
of the things they said was that they
they really kind of um
uh they they really championed the how
much how much CGI they did not use in
this is mostly practical it looks like
because like I said a lot of the fights
and [__] like that and especially that
helicopter thing at the end because I'm
watching that I was looking around Jason
Statham's head like to see the little
thing for the green screen and
everything and I couldn't see it and
then like when I looked it up later and
they said no he actually did the stuff I
mean I'm sure he was wearing a harness I
would hope because of insurance purposes
but honorable mention in the movie The
main bad guy who injected Jason Statham
with this poison he did a real good job
of that uh in this movie I thought he
was a good bad guy I've seen him in
something else I don't know that guy's
name he's hispanic guy was he on
Daredevil maybe he's a real good looking
Hispanic guy he's [__] real shredded
he was he was he's on the sauce he
um but his his physique is real nice his
acting was [__] really good spot on
for the tone of this movie he played a
great bad guy
um I thought you know what I thought the
scene was great where they brought him
his brother's hand yeah that he had cut
off and he just could like start kind of
started laughing but then like almost
crying and then like he pulls it all
together I was like that was really
great I like that and I want to see more
of the dude I don't know the guy's name
and maybe you guys drop in the comment
section but uh he's a real good looking
guy good actor [__] real well built
he's uh actually would probably be a
really good Action Hero and he never
looked him up because I kind of good but
he's a great bad guy why am I thinking
he was on what like one of the Marvel
shows yeah like I felt like a superhero
he was on Daredevil or Luke Cage or
something like I've seen him before yeah
I have two so but I can't think I think
um
I think his name will hold on I have
notes over here Jose Pablo cantillo is
that like that actor's name he's Bob
I've seen him looks good yeah I've seen
him in other things but yeah he's great
in this too like he was the guy that
injected him at the beginning and really
he was he was kind of you know he's the
main bad guy he's the target of all this
and [__] the way it goes down and
everything and he's just you see him a
lot in there and he does a lot he
delivers a great performance and a lot
of good action scenes
yeah yeah
uh Ben says Tom hasn't seen Lock Stock
in Two Smoking no I haven't seen a man
send it to me I'll [__] review it
like I said this this is a whole other
sub genre you need to get into because I
think you'd be really into all that okay
yeah because they made so many yeah
y'all are helping us out spending these
movies because we got so many other
expenses opening up the [__] cam [__]
in the studios and everything my
[__] spent 100 on dildos today
[Laughter]
for [__] props man it's ridiculous
and then I'm gonna mention any names but
some of y'all are [__] pervs too
because now I'm getting [__] uh
homemade porn and [__] from people
they're sending me uh uh clips of them
in their [__] Irish princess [__]
girlfriends and [__] [__] it's good
you guys [__] making good porn
girlfriends and [__] I don't have any
permission to mention any names but if I
get permission I'll I'll [__] I'll
give props to who said it to me instead
of me clips I'm just gonna say there's
this uh it's a big Texican guy [__]
knocking down his irish-american
princess girl with [__] Shamrocks
tattooed on her ass and a bunch of Galax
[__] script going up their sides and
everything blowing the [__] out of him I
was like man she's [__] hot
now we're trading porn with people
that's okay we'll see
we mentioned yeah
that you're a cam show everyone's just
like oh all right well we got a footage
shot and we got some footage she got
about the two scenes shot and I ran it
by uh my buddy Bill who's in the
industry and everything's oh yeah that's
good [__] you guys are gonna do great
[__] you know it came out good I
thought I I didn't expect it to come out
as good ran it by a couple of friends
that I could [__] trust who I know
it'll kind of stay with them but we'll
oh yeah yeah [__] good job here's my
girlfriend [__] blowing me it's a
great day
and um
we'll probably launch in a month or two
we'll see yeah we gotta be ready before
what we open [__] on stream mate
uh that way we have merchandise to sell
yeah because we're gonna try and get
like a backlog of yeah and stuff like
that like before we start doing the show
um we filmed a lot of stuff yesterday
but yeah we still need some more stuff
we were gonna film today too but we just
didn't yeah and guess what it's hard
is work
well yeah I mean we knew that going in
it's you know it's not that satisfying
it's like long foreplay
I can't finish you gotta [__] do it
well yeah because it's like yeah you got
to change [__] around you gotta change
angle what's next now what's next you're
worried about [__] man the angle's right
you know I'm [__] they're saying oh
we gotta change that camera over around
and then you're like I hope that's
recording audio is good so you're
working hopefully it'll wear off but
you're constantly worried about
technical [__]
yeah and you know like I said it's it's
worked just like everything else showed
some to soap she said [__] she's like
shittiest [__] hot as [__] and Jenny
looks hot as [__] in this stuff
she's got the eyelashes and her [__]
makeup looks [__] great well it's
funny how how much like just a little
thing like fake eyelash because I got
some really big like nice minky ones
yeah like yesterday at the [__]
Dollar Store man at Dollar General I was
like oh those are nice and I got they
were like nine dollars for three pairs
what was your eye shadow though too yeah
and it's like it's it's funny how
something just a little thing like that
like kind of changes your appearance
yeah uh significantly yeah but uh yeah I
wore them out last night too because
yeah we totally went out everybody liked
it we filmed all well yeah that was the
first thing because Jen was there last
night and she was that was the first
thing she said she's like oh my God
you're lashing yeah you're right yeah
she was like I can't wear those I can't
get them on and I'm like yeah they're a
[__] to get on Jenny's great actress on
the [__] doe eyes and [__] that
was a natural I feel like I didn't
expect that to happen but you know what
I mean well like I said it's not like
you know it's not like I'm in a room
full of strangers or anything it's just
it's you yeah it's just you yeah we're
holding the [__] [__] with each other
and talking [__]
here hold this send this to your other
boyfriend
he came out with that and I was just
like oh man that's great I'm [__]
hitting making her take selfies of
herself saying you send those to your
other boy
[Laughter]
you probably believe whatever hold on
she's got another one
no I know I do not like I said uh you're
more than enough it's just I just make
sure I I don't need it I don't need more
of that
I got enough to put up with yeah
you know what I mean uh xanadas said
snatch is good too I agree oh yeah
that's another one you shouldn't say no
snatches y'all are [__] introducing
me to some of these newer actions I saw
that in the theater also now that I'm
thinking about it I was kind of tied up
in the classic you know 80s and 90s
stuff but uh and then some of the new
stuff you know Expendables kind of
opened things up started to get back
into the old into the genre again but I
didn't I missed a lot of these I was
working you know what I mean there was
[__] Wars and [__] to fight but this
was like yeah this is yeah crank is good
real good like yeah that's what I'm
saying see you can't just like write off
that's why I never wanted to be one of
those [__] that was just like
oh it is only the old [__] is good like
yeah the old [__] is good but there's
always good new [__] you just I mean
sometimes you have to look for it and
sometimes it's a pain and like you can't
keep up with it and stuff but I always
say I mean particularly because I'm you
know a big horror person
um honestly I think like the last 10 20
years and horror have been like a
Renaissance there have been like some
I've seen some [__] amazing horror
film films that have come out some of my
favorite horror films have come out like
in the last 10 20 years yeah I mean my
favorite [__] is probably always going
to be 70s and 80s but I have seen some
really really good [__] Horror in the
last 10 20 years so I just you know and
I've said this before like you know 90s
and 2000s there was some great [__] that
came out then but it's like like a lot
of it was kind of like remakes or you
know wasn't really that good but I kind
of feel like you know once 2010
something like that came along like a
bunch of good [__] started coming out
and the same kind of thing you always
have to look there's always good [__]
coming out always it's hard to keep
track of and it's good to have I'm you
know glad we have you guys around
because you can uh recommend stuff yeah
recommend and help us and show us stuff
because Amazon Prime it's so much stuff
to sort through yeah if you want to send
us anything on Amazon Prime send us a
private message through you know there's
all different ways to get in contact
with jitty all right uh so it's a
private message and we'll give you the
address and uh you can just buy it on
Amazon Prime and have it delivered here
like I have hard copy so I go back and
revisit it I got a [__] whole library
of this [__] now yeah he's got in the
man cave he's gone man cave he's a whole
library with movies and because I'll
revisit [__] I'll watch [__] again and I
have a bunch of movies over there yeah
like a bunch of old Horrors and um but
yeah just uh contact Jen through with
like a you know [__] Facebook or uh
Instagram or you can drop it in the
comment here of like hey uh con contact
me and she'll contact you and give you
the address to send it to and um you can
just buy it on Amazon Prime and have it
delivered here and it'll be here like
the next day and we'll we'll review it
quick
yeah uh we review it with whoever
we review them in the order that they
arrive
yeah except like I said sometimes we
forget but sometimes we forget we gotta
I gotta go back we gotta do breakfast
club because Louie [__] sent us that
a long time ago I never got to because
we I got caught up in the move right the
move we got because we moved house yeah
because I think that was right before we
arrived actually and we uh we forgot
about it so we're gonna go back and do
breakfast club because he and he said
it's a steelbook breakfast club and I
love that [__] yeah it's a great
movie I love that movie and I want to
see all the extra [__] on there too yeah
um xanadas said I want to send the
professional with Natalie Portman and
John Reno yeah that's a great [__]
movie oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I haven't
seen that in a long time I loved it yeah
yeah Tom's seen it I've seen it there's
another movie that's like that but it's
reversed it's an older gangster woman
and a little boy called Gloria I
remember the things oh that's right
it was like the professional and she was
a a gangster girlfriend who was
protecting the little boy the little boy
had a death sentence on him because the
the the mafia wanted the entire family I
think yeah I'm pretty sure I've seen it
and the the dad said here watch him for
me and he went back to the apartment
then later the mob came killed them all
they were looking for that boy too and
she was defending the little boy that
was a good one Gloria if you guys ever
want a review of that send me Gloria
I'll review that also I liked it I mean
we could look for it and see if it's
available on it because we you know we
pay for all those Services it's
available for free yeah then we can do
it but I'd like to get a that's a and
it's almost
it feels like a little shallow movie
from where I remember it
yeah
I haven't seen it in a long time yeah
um yeah xanadas said I've got a whole
list of movies I'm sending that's
awesome thank you so much that'd be
great I mean that would be awesome good
um let's see also David June says Evil
Dead rise was super [__] good I've
heard I've been hearing a lot of good
things been hearing that the new John
Wick is really good yeah that's right
John Wick 4 is out yeah is this still in
the theater
uh maybe
has anybody seen the new um when they're
a new like Brandon Cronenberg movie that
came out infinity pool did anybody see
that yeah because I really wanted to see
it some people have said because you
know the one I want to see now is
Renfield and a couple people have seen
that and really liked it okay the uh the
lighting has changed where it's a little
brighter than it was to me I think it
looks better if you guys like this
brighter lighting go ahead and drop it
yeah because we were like I said because
we were filming I think we were all day
yesterday like not here but like over
there so we changed some lights around
and yeah did some stuff like that but it
still like looks okay I think
I think I mean you know yeah
um John Gore said I watched the mob film
State of Grace from 1991 the other night
Gary Oldman is over the top grade in
that I don't think I've ever seen that
I've heard of it but I don't think I've
ever seen it
xanna said brighter is better right is
better okay we'll leave it like this I
mean I'm always just kind of like well
maybe if it stays dark like it will look
more mysterious I think that looks good
from what I'm seeing it does yeah it
does actually probably the colors look
brighter yeah Tammy said it looks okay
[Laughter]
I mean you know we
there's still lights back there we still
have that ring light there yeah but we
moved where'd you get those lights from
the other room from back here oh they
were um not they were like uh yellows
and uh a green and I changed them both
to Reds and put them there yeah we have
here I'm gonna show you guys on the
screen what we did this is uh
be careful yeah
that is
what we have going on the side
yeah that's our porn Studio that's the
background we had a couch over there but
we moved it moved it away he moved it
into the man cave yeah it's light so you
can I can move it back it's like it's
not a couch it's like a gay bed yeah and
it's like in two pieces yeah but you can
move it from like place to place so he's
gonna put it in the man cave and then
we're just gonna move it back in here
whenever we need your spots at the end
there uh hold on where's box shoulder
oops duh
move more I never get that right I
always do it like the wrong way first
time yeah yeah
just blocks to Target motion sickness
anyone
Santa says behind the scenes
uh also says Jenny is glowing am I
really like is that good or bad I'm not
really sure
not really sure
um I can actually show some shots
just promotional shots
from photo shoots
they're all non-nudes and stuff Santa
just said I'm going to send Bad
Lieutenant as well oh I hope I wish you
would because I love bad luck yeah yeah
we want to see a Bad Lieutenant man
[__] Harvey Kai so I'll run around
naked like a crazy person
[Laughter]
uh Danny Rowling said would you guys
ever review the film version of a
haunting in Georgia starring Chad
Michael Murray for haunting Monday
review
I kind of remember hearing about that
but I don't know if I ever watched the
movie
xanadas said I'll send that next I guess
you mean like that looks well don't like
show no they can't see that they kiss
Christ I'm showing it to you I know that
but it's just kind of I was like don't
put that on there they'll kick us off
YouTube no no I was just showing you
some dirty ass [__] right there
why do you do that like in the middle of
the show here here look how hot that is
I know I was there it's just us
but it's just I thought you were just
gonna turn it around again check that
[__] out and I was like no don't do that
no don't do that we're gonna get like
demonetized
but uh but yeah
[Laughter]
Xander said I'll send that next so I
guess he means like badly tenant yeah
okay which yeah that'd be awesome for
them being real good yeah I like that
it's been a long time that's another
that's another able for era yeah it's
been a long time because I've seen it I
remember it kind of shocked me when I
saw it
yeah it's a long time ago yeah I haven't
seen it in probably like 20 years did I
see that in the theater maybe I remember
only a couple scenes of from it but
[__] I was like this movie's [__]
bad
like I said it's able for Aaron he's
kind of fun but I might have seen at the
theater because I kind of feel like
during the time that that came out like
in the because I graduated from high
school in 1990. so like from the late
80s to probably like 2 000 I saw a lot
of movies in the theater like especially
because I was still living in Daytona
and they had a dollar theater so I would
always wait so me and my friend were
like really into like movies and me and
her would like they're like hey it's you
know Friday night or whatever let's go
spend two dollars and like go see this
movie you had to wait a couple weeks
obviously for it to go to the cheap
theater but you know it was like a cheap
[__] night out you know you just like
get some pizza at the house and then you
would go and [__] man pizza sounds
good two dollars to yeah I'm gonna make
some pizza yeah you guys sound good yeah
okay all right I'll make some pizza did
I eat today oh yeah hey I figured that
sandwich that's right you brought me a
Smoker smoked turkey look how look how
cute he is yeah I was just like working
and I totally forgot I didn't have
breakfast or nothing like that because I
just didn't think about it well I mean
we slept kind of late because we went
out last night
um but
so I'm just like in here working because
I was like man I have so much stuff to
do because we filmed all day yesterday
so I didn't have time to do like a lot
of stuff that uh that I would normally
do like I said today I put up the um uh
on scare Salon I put up a video over
there which is like half an hour long so
if you wanna go watch that you can but
um so yeah so I'm just like working and
I didn't even think about food and then
he just like comes up with a plate and
he's like thought you wanna you might
want a shark I do that all the time
she comes home to work I got dinner
ready I'm gonna go [__] housewife
it's pretty awesome I gotta say I really
do appreciate glad you appreciate that
yeah I do appreciate it yeah well you're
like take care of a [__] man
he takes care of a [__] no seriously
the minute I like I walk in the door I
get home from work like right around six
ish and uh usually as soon as I walk in
he's like he's like oh I got tacos five
minutes or something like that so I'm
like okay just let me go put my [__]
down and I usually have to pee because
I've been sitting in the car for more
than an hour so I usually have to pee
when I go yeah we're gonna try to get
her back home working these new Pro new
projects I think we can beat that just
man what
we're just not corporate people
we like to have our own businesses and
running from the house and we're
entertainers you know we just
because it's killed her I think a lot of
what gets her is that damn two hours
worth of commuting a day
and flushing 300 a month down the toilet
and [__] fuel
yeah it's not yeah it's not great and
everything she's doing she could be
doing from home
for them I probably yeah yeah there's no
reason for even go it's just a retro
company
um
but you know
some days I don't mind it but some days
I'm just kind of like oh man it's like
it's you and it's normally it's not the
morning isn't too bad yeah um just
because I leave so early that like
usually the traffic isn't bad but like
coming home is like a [__] because
everyone's leaving at the same time yeah
I'm always [__] stressing because
that old [__] Taurus or hers if that
[__] breaks then that job's gone because
I don't have enough money to fix that
[__] no I don't either and I'd be like
and and then that means that I'd have to
[__] buy a new car for her
I could do it on my credit
not with her credit I would never I can
do it on my credit and I'm not sure
it'd really work out money-wise to pay
off for a new car not right now not
until credit cards get paid off because
she's got some credit cards you gotta
pay off but we're gonna work well you
know I'm [__] our own projects I
think we can [__]
make that up I mean we can [__] yeah
we're we're gonna try and start like you
know making some [__] side money
doing another side hustle yeah and then
hopefully eventually I mean even even an
extra one thousand dollars a month would
make a huge difference it would yeah
that would be that would be a very very
helpful but yeah well I mean we'll see
how it goes like I said you know it's
another thing and it's still I mean it's
fun I'm not gonna say that but it is
still like a lot of work like I have to
sort through all the footage that we
shot yesterday and like edit it together
and uh
some cool [__] that we can sell for a
few bucks and you know what I mean yeah
it well yeah sell for a few bucks
the name of that game is that you have
to have a lot of material that's what
I'm saying that's so in a lot of places
right it's residual though so once it's
done it sits back there and makes money
and like a back catalog
we need a couple hundred videos if we
had a couple hundred videos that might
be two thousand dollars a month right
there
on a bunch of different platforms but it
takes a long time to accrue 200 [__]
videos yeah
I mean this the footage we shot
yesterday we could probably get two or
three videos out of that because it was
eight I think two probably two two I
think
and one good thing about video is that
if you say look man this needs to be
five or six minutes long well you got
the video there you can see what you're
wearing I can recreate that [__]
scene we'll just reshoot some [__] and
[__] re-edit it in there so if I
could all happen on the same day yeah I
remember what outfit so yeah you got a
record of it it's in the video right
and uh so
and this is just the way it is even in
Pro-Am and amateur stuff that you guys
are looking at not all that is [__]
um spontaneous it's made to look
spontaneous
but uh just depends on what it is
some of it really is but you can tell
the difference
then I said my commute is only 10
minutes so I'd hate or three hours she's
[__] doing an hour each way yeah so
it's like an hour in the morning and
like I said I leave the house at 6 30 in
the morning
so you know
it's not it's like I said morning isn't
too bad because the traffic isn't bad
and I don't I don't get on like the main
Highway like I don't take I-4 or
anything because [__] that noise but we
got a jam-packed schedule but we're
still going to be doing um 13 o'clock
and shouldn't you guys shouldn't really
notice much difference other than that
we're talking about other stuff that
we're doing
because for for now we're going to be
jam-packed if other things starts making
money and then she leaves uh the graphic
design job then that'll actually free up
some time and we'll just be able to make
more of our own products well yeah that
would be cool because we could not only
make some more like you know of the
stuff that now we're talking about but I
can make more you know I can get back to
doing like my horror reviews and stuff
like that because now it's like I'm only
doing like one a week and before I was
doing like several a week you know but
I don't know we'll see how it goes we'll
see yeah uh our Tuesday Danny Rowling
says our Tuesday movie reviews done away
with
um yeah I I kind of feel like we're just
not because Tuesday nights that's
usually that's your bike night yeah
that's when he goes down to downtown
Sanford and hangs out with with the
bikers yeah uh and looking at all the
motorcycles and stuff yeah that's kind
of his and you can follow me on
Instagram that's his me time yeah and
you can follow me on Instagram I'm
always posting videos from that
yeah on my Instagram Thomas Ross he goes
like you've gone pretty much every week
right yeah yeah I'll usually post two or
three little Quick videos and uh it's a
it's a mixed crowd of Harleys and sport
bikes uh we have uh guys and a few girls
usually sport bike girls there's little
Smalls I didn't get I didn't get a video
a little Smalls and then there's a
little Smalls was like 410 on her little
[__] sport bike she was [__] funny
uh I'll I'll I'll get better videos of
them soon
and then uh so you'll there's biker
girls too on it
yeah we're hanging out at a place called
Throwbacks and Throwbacks is a bar that
has free 80s video games they're they're
the one up video games in there yeah but
they're free you can just go in there
and play them you know like all the
[__] Street Fighters even Street
Fighter even puzzle fighter [__] the
Star Wars games uh [__] Frogger uh
all the Miss Pac-Mans and Pac-Man games
are in there and you can just select
which each each console might have five
or six games on it and you can just go
in there and play free video games too
and drink beer
and uh listen to music
it's pretty good it's mostly like a
college crowd and bikers
yeah so that's what Tom does on Tuesday
yeah so so usually when I come home on
Tuesday night like he's not home so
usually I just run up to Publix or the
Chinese place and get something for
dinner and just kind of chill out and
watch MST or something you know what I
mean yeah murder horn assassin about the
upcoming projects if you need
memberships no
you do have a membership set up on this
channel you probably thought I was
talking about your upcoming projects
that's what you said I don't know oh I
don't know what he's talking about I
don't know either well we don't
understand dude
um somebody said American Military 100
said uh crank was a really fun flick
glad you guys are reviewing it it was
super fun we had a blast like Washington
yeah I gave it five out of five five out
of five inside its genre it did exactly
what like I said it's very like
hyperactive like a lot of movies from
that era were but it knows what it is
and it just like just sets out to
entertain you good quality a good
quality flick and that it it delivers
it's good in its genre yeah five out of
five Danny Rowling said what is
tomorrow's a haunting episode gonna be
we are going to do season five episode
four which is called House of Horrors
okay this one is about the Allen house
which uh they also did on Paranormal
Witness yeah I remember this one yeah um
you know so that's kind of and I think
the dude wrote a book about it too if
I'm we might have done a show about the
Allen house like a long time ago
but um I don't think we've ever talked
about this specific haunting episode so
that's the next one because like I said
we've kind of worked through all the
first four seasons so we're working
through season five now so that's the
one that we're gonna do and like I said
I'm pretty familiar with this story
because it was on Paranormal Witness and
it's been on a couple of other shows as
well that dude kind of like did the
rounds
of the you know what I mean of all the
Paranormal stuff like when his book came
out xanadas said I'll keep sending
movies so don't worry about anything
thank you very much that's awesome
that's awesome
um you know because I I feel like
there's a lot of stuff that Tom would
probably like that he hasn't seen you
know yeah I kind of missed a lot of the
2000s yeah yeah yeah I was busy yeah it
was Contracting at that time so I
thought is that Pokey yeah yeah yeah 2
000 you know 2 000 when When The War
started
you know around 9 11 and then to around
2008 or nine I was I was too busy I
didn't watch any movies yeah
so yeah you missed like a whole yeah
it's almost a decade pretty much yeah
because a lot of times I'll say like oh
haven't you seen this you love that and
he's like nope never seen it yeah I
never saw it yeah and what was funny is
that the 2000s look like a really good
decade I liked the fashion and a lot of
good [__] was happening it was kind of
seemed like it was a little more vibrant
than the 90s
uh but I missed it I was [__]
training foreign troops and [__] yeah
and cops yeah
Danny Rowling said some personal trainer
role play videos would be hot to see
interesting
with video we can be more creative I
want to do like cosplay type elements
and there's a bunch of [__] we can do
that is not necessarily the bread and
butter the bread and butter is going to
be uh our stream mate and our Live Gold
shows and just live shows something and
we're gonna have regulars over there too
and you guys once that shit's all set up
you'll be welcome to come hang out with
us on stream mate yeah like I said I
mean if you think it's it'd be weird
then yeah if you're not comfortable than
whatever but you know here's the thing
when we broadcast on stream mate it's
it's maybe R-rated we're not nude or
doing anything like that that can only
happen in private on stream B yeah so
you pay to go in to private and uh we'll
do you know hour-long shows or whatever
and anything can happen we'll be talking
you know [__] and doing stuff and just
and you know [__] accepting tips and
the show doesn't start until the price
is met right so we're probably not gonna
do anything until we get like
200 bucks and then we'll do a show yeah
we'll just be like sitting around
shooting the [__] like we would do and
we'll set minimum buy-ins like you okay
you can't come in unless it's you know
each viewer [__] does 25 bucks or 20
bucks for the hour
and you might have only four or five
people watching some people have paid 70
you know or whatever so we don't do
anything in public
it's not like ChatterBait right where
you're [__] doing sex acts to the
world and 5 000 people are watching you
and only two are paying uh [__] that no
I'd be uncomfortable I feel like I'd be
like a used up [__]
I'd be like having sex and [__] in front
of a Coliseum full of people and like
four or five people paid
[Laughter]
you know we can do stuff in front of
four or five paid customers and you
talking to them you know they're regular
people right you know we we've already
done the research talked to people that
do this for a living they're just
regular people working people and
a lot of them are married and you know
their wives don't [__] them or you know
or they're you know maybe they got
medical problems or they're obese baby
and they just don't get any action and
they're more lonely than they are
they're not that creepy they're just
regular yeah if they're creepy you can
kick them out you don't have to deal
with anybody right
you know
Danny rolling said better hope no one
leaks your videos on xhamster no that
happens anyway it happens anyway I mean
um everything that I've seen about it
like you know all the research I was
doing they're like well it's pretty much
unavoidable like it's probably gonna
happen
um basically the only way you can combat
it is just like make a lot of stuff you
make so much stuff that it doesn't
matter right okay because you're pretty
much you're not making a living off of
one video
another thing is is that video sales is
only a one portion of of the revenue
most of the revenues through streamate
live interaction
I mean you can sit there and drink and
talk [__] and all night long make
[__] five duck bucks a pop just
[__] Jenny flashing her tits I mean
that they got girls that do that that'll
stream for six hours make a hundred
dollars just because they flash their
tits a couple times yeah so you know
we're from this background anyway we
know people in
[__] porn and well we told our
friends about it last night we went to
Barbarella and they were just kind of
like yeah okay yeah because I'm not
gonna mention any names but a good
friend of mine and [__] He's well
known and his wife is well known and
they make all kinds of money just
selling nude photos of her right and
she's pushing 50 herself she's gorgeous
though you know she's you know
her and Jake are standing right next to
each other they you know I'm [__]
they look like models you know but um
there's a lot of stuff going on y'all
don't know about no matter cool people
make money of doing this a lot of times
they do well I mean why wouldn't you if
you know yeah if you're kind of popular
there's a demand for it
you know and really in that in that
particular industry that we're talking
about I'm not the big draw I'd be more
like the MC Jenny's kind of more like
the bait that's what the guys are paying
to see
but what I am I'm being more like a
surrogate like uh
you're gonna be me basically you know
it's not about [__] because I want to
get some gear like GoPro so I can go I
want to get I want to grow up GoPro
uh they're expensive that might be a
couple months from now uh but that way I
can go uh point of view yeah that's one
of the things the viewer can see my
point of view of the [__] right and
these are guys and they're paying and
they're
paid customers and they can [__] see
what it's like what's like from Tom's
point of view you know Jenny likes other
point of views though to the third
person she's like I've never seen you
from that angle man you look great
they're like that's what it looks like
she's like seeing [__] what it looks
like me going doggy on back up you know
yeah I was like well I never get to see
that angle so it's like neat to see it
that's what it looks like yeah right and
I was like that's pretty awesome like I
never get to see that yeah and I'm
dressed up in [__] boots and [__] I'm
not even naked and I'm [__] [__]
hat on you know yeah that's right yeah I
had a hat on no I didn't have a hat on
didn't I had a hat on parts of it yeah
parts of it yeah
Zach said uh hey y'all I saw the pics
that Tom sent me yesterday more of Jenny
than I ever expected to see yeah yeah
yeah yeah I didn't know which one he
said oh no there's they're they're
mostly just uh in between you know like
the the shots of us [__] in between
segments
oh yeah okay [__] like that right yeah
Daniel Rowling said uh Pokey nip shots
and camel toe shots upskirt shots are
better than nudity in my opinion yeah
some people are kind of more into that
because it's more like suggestive I get
that I get that yeah and and uh our um
our other channel is going to be very
fetish oriented so
we're friendly to all that too people
want what they can't have uh we'll give
you what you want
but some guys don't want easy you know
it just depends on depends on what's
Happening you just go with the flow yeah
that's what I'm trying to play uh Zach
said at what point does Jenny get to
break out the strap-on
we have had this discussion well see
that's what's kind of great about I told
him I'm like I know this is kind of
weird but it's like I'm kind of liking
this because it's like it kind of opens
up like all these conversations that
maybe you wouldn't have with your
significance otherwise you see we've
done our research okay and there have
been [__] couples acts before where
rich guys have gotten into the [__]
couple all right and they start [__]
throwing [__] tons of money at the
couple
for things like that that I want you to
because you don't like he doesn't like
the guy that much I want you to [__]
Peg the [__] out of that dude right
here's five thousand dollars to do it
you're gonna have to [__] really
reach down you know what I mean and
[__] grab your think about it man and
[__] realize that hey man that's a
car or a motorcycle five thousand
[__] dollars
that is like what would you do it's not
like this dude is pegging at you it's
your girlfriend or your wife begging you
right and you're like that's a lot of
money
you know
[Laughter]
so me and you I ain't gonna give the
price Jenny knows what the price is I
know it's at the thousands I'm not gonna
say it's in the thousands but we were
talking about this isn't it that last
night and here's the thing well because
the friend that we told he asked the
same question yeah he asked the same
question he said exactly he's like what
if hypothetically yeah he
he kind of does this kind of stuff so
he's like exactly like you already do he
already wanted to see he was trying to
find my weaknesses
so they're very good friends of ours
that's why yeah yeah so so they kind of
knew I didn't tell him the price but
everything has a price and if you
[__] as man as you are
if a dude came at you with a million
dollars and you walked away from that
I'd call you a fool
yeah that would be a million that would
be really dumb
because it's a million dollars for
something that's only gonna last a few
minutes and dudes have been captured by
[__] enemy [__] troops and raped
right [__] POW camps and [__] all
right didn't make him less than a man
you got you know he had no choice right
exactly exactly yeah so
and and [__] cam and [__] is all fun
and games and this isn't another person
doing it this is your girlfriend yeah
it's just like I said it's just me a
million dollars is a million [__]
dollars it's just me okay if you said
you'd walk away from that I'd say you're
a [__] liar we'll see well the thing
about it too is if somebody actually
like hypothetically wanted to give you a
million dollars for that like you would
never have to do it ever again because
you'd have a million dollars you got a
million bucks [__] yeah I'm ready I'm
gonna pay somebody hundred thousand
dollars to [__] you in there
I
wouldn't that be something yeah that
might be worth it yeah
but uh no so but here's the deal in
general in general that [__] like we're
getting super chats now what in in
England said this [__] is why I love
y'all
thank you thank you here's the thing
though [__] unless it was
[__] crowdsourcing the [__] you
know what I mean we had so many fans are
like this [__] Tom [__] [__] and you
got a thousand people [__] all all
[__] chip contributing 100 bucks or
something like that it ain't gonna
happen that's not what that's not what
average caming is right most of it's
load it's just like little [__] a little
[__] right and uh most of it is twenty
dollars here twenty dollars there and
it's seven guys each paying [__]
thirty dollars forty dollars and it's
and really their tastes are kind of
pedestrian most of them
what they want isn't very isn't exotic
really basic [__] yeah I mean a lot of
the stuff they're asking for is just
like real basic just and most of the
[__] that they want only lasts about
three or four minutes right because that
motherfucker's got pecker in hand he's
ready to [__] go like I said he's got
the lube on it over here and the tissue
here man suck on this and [__] you
know suck on this and just let me do my
thing okay fine because there's all kind
of private messages going on so you go
private [__] let dude you're you're
helping this jack off that's that's all
you're doing and to public service
what it is
you never see the guy right unless he
wants to go cam to cam and that costs
money nothing's free uh if you go into
something like stream mate or
it's
um if you don't know what you do and you
can actually spend a lot you can
accidentally spend a lot of money it's
almost like a damn Carnival that site is
built uh it's got a lot of security too
you can't go in there and [__] around
you'll get booted immediately
I like that about it you know that's
what I like about that one that's why we
chose to use that platform yeah if
you're just rude to somebody they you're
gone yeah you're not that's good I don't
want a bunch of [__] muscles in there
well the streammates good service they
uh they know they they know they want
their models to feel safe and yeah they
want anybody making fun of their models
you know and they got models of all
different kinds they got fat girls and
[__] fat dudes I mean there's a
massive like even just scrolling through
like the top like stuff I was just like
there's every single thing you could
imagine and that's something for
everybody yeah
um with our sets and our knowledge and
our ability to edit video and lighting
and everything when it's Jenny and I
have to enter at the top echelon
you know because when we show up we're
going to have new status and when you
have new status you get a lot of volume
and during that time you have to have a
lot of stuff to sell so you can maximize
your traffic so that's right yeah so
we're trying to like have a lot of stuff
like we were before we opened the [__]
so that way we have a good 20 videos
that are ten dollars to twenty dollars
each and [__] uh because you can
either give those away as bonuses for
certain things and trade or you can just
sell those uh and then there's all the
live stuff and then there's the chat
there's a lot of chatting going on you
can drink during the [__] and it's it's
just
it's more fun than everybody everything
else time goes by really fast on it
evidently
um and the profits are good
they take 65 percent
but it doesn't matter it there's quite a
bit of volume
and you're paying for their services and
their security and they're they're like
bouncers yeah get people out yeah I like
that because I don't want to have to
deal with like that kind of [__] you
know what I mean Jones Perkins said what
the hell did I just walk into well you
had to go back and watch the video I
mean you know how this goes well
actually we were talking about the money
all we gotta do is start talking about
sex and sex cells and then [__] uh
see you're right about that how much was
that yeah thank you thank you thank you
Jeff ER but once it's all once it's all
ready to go you guys will be welcome and
if you guys show up at streammate uh
it's easy to go in you just give them
your credit card numbers and they're
good with it because I opened up an
account so I could try out the site from
the outside
and I was satisfied with what I saw on
um you can't really get away with
anything
and uh yeah I like that yeah I like that
they're kind of like you crack down on
it then I closed my account went out I
just wanted to see what it's like from
the customer yeah he was trying to see
it from like because well one thing he
said like he messaged me because he's
like I'm checking like I opened an
account like to see you know what I
could because you have to kind of have
an account to do anything and so he's
like one thing I kind of like at least
from the performer part of you is it's
like it's really really easy he's like
because the tip button and the exit
button are like right now right next to
each other in the same color he's like
and I accidentally like tipped this girl
like when I was trying to leave the room
actually tipped her five bucks and I was
like he was like whoops yeah yeah so you
got to watch it he's like but that's
good like from our point of view too
because people might be tipping
accidentally the whole thing is gamified
like a carnival
all right but once you understand how to
navigate through it it's easy but you
guys are welcome to come talk to us over
there and like I said
and you can talk in private to us
so so other members can't see what it is
you're talking about
and anything that happens we go in
private to do that
so no one nobody knows now some people
if it's a show
uh like we start a gold show and the
show has already started and it'll say
how long the show is going to go for it
you can buy into the show buy your way
in so if the show starts you won't be
able to see us unless you buy in right
and there's gonna be minimum buy-ins and
stuff but
yeah we're this is we've been it's gonna
be like this but with less limitations
yeah that's basically what I was
shooting for I was just like I wanted to
be like a Sidetrack show yeah but where
[__] might get real at some point that's
you know that's that's how and we'll be
drinking and [__] it'll be fun it'll be
fun
uh Zach says speaking of me and my folks
are thinking of going to Florida this
summer and I told them about you guys
yeah oh
and xanna said my friend who's in
Florida right now is talking about
public subs and I thought of you guys
yeah um that kind of makes Publix has
the best subs and it's a grocery store
if you guys know what we're talking
about has the best subs they got good
daily they got some of the best ice
cream Publix ice cream is [__] their
brand is not really good they got their
own Creamery and everything that makes
it makes their [__] and they're up there
with BlueBell ice cream even though I
kind of prefer Bluebell seems like it
tastes like it has a little more eggs in
it it's stretchier yeah but Publix brand
ice cream is [__] fantastic Xanax
said he said it was the best sub he ever
had oh yeah public Subs are no [__]
joke man no joke the bread is good this
is everything on it and then you can go
for the deluxe meat package The Boar's
Head yeah you can get the Publix meat
that's good too it's good too yeah like
it's like a dollar issue uh more yeah
for Boar's Head I think it's the bread
that makes it though man
is really good yeah blow Subways out of
the water Subway can't [__] compete
with Publix no way
actually look at the firehouse can't
compete with the Publix Firehouse is
kind of more concerned with like hot
Subs I kind of feel I've only been there
like once or twice they're good but I
like Publix I do too my gift and Publix
is right down the street so if I'm gonna
get a sub I'm gonna go there I mean we
do I think we have a Jimmy John's like
maybe a couple miles from here but I've
never been to that one Zach says uh just
look like you're into it because I've
been in ChatterBait a few times and some
of the guys there just look like they
hate their life and it's kind of
depressing just like ChatterBait is a
[__] I would never go to Chaturbate
[__] I know professional porn star
girls that will not do ChatterBait
because they just say it just it just
feels used up
we got 10 000 people watching and only
four paid yeah she made a couple hundred
bucks but it's not worth it it doesn't
really sound like much fun no [__] like
I said I wanna I just want to go in
there and have a good time I don't
really you know yeah I want to make
money and [__] like that but it's like I
I wouldn't be doing this if I didn't
think it was going to be fun if I
thought it was going to be like a bummer
and depressing and stuff I wouldn't do
it yeah it's just us right you know
that's what I mean it's like that's
that's why I'm not bothered about it
because I'm like look it's just you and
me in the room it's like yeah there's
other people watching but we can't like
see them yeah suggestions and you guys
can see what the [__] going on and
it's not and here's the thing uh
successful couple shows are only like 10
percent sex the rest of it is all just
other entertainment talking and [__]
it's just talking to regulars and same
[__] we're doing now uh there there's a
sexual elements to it of course there's
content in there like that
but that's not what's driving it what's
driving it is other [__] shenanigans
yeah so we're actually kind of cut out
for that kind of work yeah you guys only
know certain parts of us because we're
on YouTube
yeah you can't get away with life no
we're yeah we're from goth fetish
Club background scenes and we know
people that do this for a living and
just
it's we're at the point now where
the growth of the business really
[__] would kind of be fools not to go
in that direction
I mean we could have been escorts
[__] fetish dominatrix fed a fetish
dominatrist as if we wanted to we're
[__] Dobbs but now then you have to
leave the house
we don't really want to do that just
have a stream mate and [__] sell porn
yeah Jeffy Hart said I just had the
Publix Italian sub for lunch oh yeah
yeah yeah my very favorite is the roast
beef and swiss on multigrain yeah me too
roast beef is with multigrain with fresh
spinach yeah banana peppers yeah onions
I like tomatoes a little bit of the
vinaigrette on it I like tomatoes on my
mind yeah yeah I don't like the tomatoes
I do I like to keep anything that real
watery off the sandwich yeah I get it
and I like the Swiss Swiss swiss cheese
man she's good Jones Perkins said does
that mean I get to see some boobies oh
yeah more than that yeah well not on
here obviously it's YouTube no we're
talking about on we're talking streaming
that's what we're gonna be doing yeah so
yeah
boobies if you're into that uh Ian
England said Subway is trash it is so is
trash
like I used to eat there because
sometimes because there was one right
next to my work and if I forgot my lunch
one day or something like that I could
just go over there and get a sandwich
but yeah it's not great their bread is
not great
I've heard they've revamped some [__]
but I haven't been there since then yeah
we have one there's actually a Subway in
the back of the Circle K like right by
our house but I've never gotten a
sandwich there I can do if you guys are
probably interested
curious like what it was like I can do
some teaser photos here of us in between
Zach says I don't know if I ever
mentioned but a couple years ago I kind
of went on a date with a dude who did
PornHub videos I liked the PornHub
videos I liked and it was still kind of
like meeting a celebrity is that weird
yeah
no that's not weird all right this just
quit
hey that was boobs yeah but you can't
really see
don't do that that's [__] okay you can't
see anything there's two it's too low
res yeah but that's us doing stuff
oh
you can see nothing I knew he was gonna
do that I just I knew it I knew it all
right it's just face shots and [__]
right here hey murder Hornet just joined
yeah he became a member you did it oh I
can't remember of this channel yeah
right great what does that allow yeah
what you get you're a little see you
you're now you're a little green and you
get your little thing and you know what
I mean it's only like a couple bucks a
month or something like that okay here's
this is not non-nude but here's Jen
making see look at this lash is awesome
I like I said I got them at Dollar
General
like some black uh glue yeah we're
making clips for Instagram type stuff
like for advertisement that's just a
company advertisement you can I'm
getting a glare
but that's all just some raw video that
I'll be editing into something look how
cute her eyes look well and people are
probably like wow they because they
hardly ever see me without glasses on
yeah and it was hilarious because I
can't really wear glasses with those
lashes because they're so long and so
like when I put the glasses on it just
it's against glasses so it's like so
every time like he would film some [__]
and he'd show it to me I'm like I can't
see that it just looks like a big flurry
nothing
I'm like I'm sure it probably looks good
I guess I don't know
um Jeff yard said have you guys ever
considered doing a discussion on Jared
Fogle the subway guy that [__] was so
messed up oh you know what that's
actually a really good idea I never
thought about doing a show about him but
we probably should one of these days let
me write it up sometimes I don't need
paper
why do you look like someone completely
different in that video you just showed
us now it's the eye makeup and the fact
that I don't have glasses on I think
like you guys are used to seeing me with
glasses because I can't really see I
can't read without it you think she
looks different in that photo you have
no idea how different she looks when she
has blue contacts in we were talking
about that last night too I need to get
some contact yeah when she puts I have
some I have red ones and I have like
some snake eye ones that I use for my
Medusa costume but I had some ice blue
ones a while back and they looked super
cool but I looked like a completely
different person with those in yeah
which is weird because like I said it's
so minor it makes a big difference so
eye color yeah it makes a huge
difference it does
[Laughter]
but yeah that's well that's the thing
that's kind of more what I look like
when I go out I guess because I don't
usually wear glasses out because I don't
have to because I don't have to read
anything no she looks like when she's
made up and she's got everything right
she looks just like any other Instagram
girl so most of the time when we're
doing the show I just kind of want to be
comfortable or I've been at work all day
and I just haven't redone my makeup or
anything like that so I just kind of
like
Zach says I always wished I had green
eyes they're so pretty thank you I got
green eyes
uh Xander said I love long dark straight
hair on a woman yeah that's I mean
obviously that's a wig I have long
straight dark hair but I have bangs you
know what I mean uh Zach says my eyes
are so dark brown they usually look
black and I think it freaks people out
yeah mine uh same same here mine are
very very dark brown obviously so they
also look kind of black
murder Hornets had got my flash bulbs in
yeah yeah I preached what do you want
folks what's up she's just like
screaming all right so we kind of
stopped talking about the movie a long
time ago but you know it became a show
we got we got [__] we got to do we gotta
hit the gym and then we got to watch we
gotta watch a haunting yeah oh [__] it's
like almost 8 30. so it's gonna but
we're promo and uh the stream mate and
all the other uh adults content that
we're gonna be making you guys are gonna
enjoy I know you guys you guys are
already sending me your adult adult
content and your adult content is pretty
good I ain't mentioned any names but I'm
like I don't think they're here right
now yeah he'll see this though
dude
I offer you're a [__] offer you a
[__] job
what would help produce your [__] okay
all right but uh yeah so once again
thank you very much for stopping by
thank you very much Xander for sending
us the movie and uh also he says I'll
send Bad Lieutenant next thank you very
much I'd appreciate that because yeah I
really really like that movie
um Zach says don't forget to watch that
finished dominatrix movie by the way uh
I'll send you the trailer later yeah I
think that's on shutter like I said so
I'll eventually get around to watching
that so okay so remember tomorrow is
Monday so we're doing a haunting Mondays
as I mentioned earlier if you weren't
here we're doing a house of horrors
which is season five episode four I
think so if you want to watch it ahead
of time like before we do the show
that's the one we're gonna do so uh yeah
have a good rest of your weekend and
evening you guys and we will see you
guys again tomorrow good night